[Musique]
j'ai dit que l'on devait faire rentrer
la lumière dans le corps soit à travers
la peau soit d'une autre manière
puis je vois que le désinfectant la
somme en une minute et ce qu'il ya moyen
de faire quelque chose comme ça avec une
injection à l'intérieur ou presque comme
un nettoyage
comme vous le voyez ça pénètrent dans
les poumons et ça crée un énorme effet
il serait donc intéressant de le
vérifier
[Musique]
regardez les accidents d'automobile qui
sont bien plus nombreux que tous les
chiffres dont nous parlons cela ne veut
pas dire pour autant que nous allons
dire à tout le monde on arrête de
conduire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout
c'est un ennemi très brillant vous savez
c'est un brillant et demi il développe
des médicaments comme les antibiotiques
on peut le voir les antibiotiques
étaient utilisées pour résoudre tous les
problèmes maintenant l'un des plus gros
problèmes du monde et que le germe est
devenu si brion que les antibiotiques ne
peuvent pas le suivre
[Musique]
non
ban
on
en